welcome to a video on how to make a
resume for the role of business analyst
if you're considering applying for a job
in this field or simply want to improve
your current resume this video is for
you business analyst is a popular job
role in the corporate world and a
well-crafted resume can help you stand
out from the other applicants in this
video we will discuss some essential
aspects of resume for a business analyst
job including the sections you need to
include the language you should use and
some common mistakes toward Additionally
you will learn about the importance of
matching your resume to the job
descriptions and how to use keywords
effectively we'll also provide examples
of business analysts resuming that you
can use as models for your own in
conclusion with the right Knowledge and
Skills you can create a strong and
effective resume for a business analyst
job so if you're ready to take the first
step in your career as a business
analyst sit back and let's get started
now before moving forward let me ask you
a quick question
so which of the following is not a
primary responsibility of a business
analyst option A is gathering and
analyzing requirements option b is
conducting market research
option C is designing software
application and option D is facilitating
communication between stakeholders
now you can pause this video and answer
in the comment section below
now let's start with the first topic
that is importance of well crafted
business analysts resuming so a
well-crafted business analyst resume is
crucial because it serves as a first
impression when applying for job
opportunities it highlights your skills
experience and achievements in a concise
and organized manner making it easier
for employers to access your
qualifications
a strong resume showcases your ability
to analyze complex problems communicate
effectively and provide valuable
insights to drive business success
it increases your chances of getting
noticed by hiring managers leading to
more interview invitations
by presenting your skills and
accomplishments clearly a well-crafted
resume Studio professionalism and
competence
now let's have a look at some key
Elements of Effective business analyst
resume
so the first point is crafting a
captivating summary statement
your resume summary statement is like a
short introduction about yourself and
what you want to achieve in your career
it's important to use this section to
talk about the skills and experience and
achievements that are most relevant to
the job you are applying for
take the time to customize your summary
statement so that it fits the specific
requirements for the job by doing this
you can make a strong first impression
and cache the interest of employers
right away showcasing what makes you
unique and valuable in a clear and
persuasive way will help you stand out
from other applicants next is
highlighting your technical skills
so as a business analyst possessing
strong technical skills is essential
employers often see candidates who are
proficient in various tools
methodologies and software applications
create a dedicated section in your
resume to outline your technical
impedance including skills such as SQL
data modeling process mapping business
intelligence tools and project
management software
additionally mention any certifications
or specialized training you have
acquired to further and enhance your
credibility the next is emphasizing your
educational background
while experience and skill holds
significant weight in the business
analyst field your education background
should not be overlooked include your
academic achievements such as degree
certifications and relevant coursework
in a separate section if you haven't
completed any industry specific
certifications or Advanced training
programs be sure to highlight them this
demonstrates your commitment to the
professional growth and continuous
learning
now let us understand structuring your
business analyst resume for Success so
the first step while structuring your
business analyst resume for success is
choosing the right resume format
so when it comes to resume formats there
are three primary options chronological
functional and hybrid for most business
analyst roles the chronological format
is preferred this format focuses on your
work history presenting it in a reverse
chronological order it allows employers
to see your career progression and
easily access your stability for the
rule however if you are transitioning
into a business analyst field or have a
significant gaps in your employment
history a functional or hybrid format
may be more appropriate
now next is tailoring your resume for
each application
to maximize your chances of success
tailor your business analysts resume for
each job application
carefully review the job description and
identify the specific skills and
qualifications sought by the employer
customize your resume accordingly
highlighting the most relevant
experiences and accomplishments
by aligning your resume with the
specific needs of the employer you
demonstrate your understanding of the
rule and increase your chances of
securing an interview now coming to the
next part which is writing style
now when creating a business analysis
you may it is crucial to use Clear
concise and professional language
so use action verbs being bullet points
with action verbs to convey your
achievements and responsibilities
effectively examples include analyzed
facilitated
implemented developed managed and
presented
next is quantify achievements so
whenever possible quantify your
accomplishments to provide tangible
evidence of your impact for instance
instead of stating improved project
efficiency you could say increased
project efficiency by 20 through process
optimization now the third would be be
specific
provide concrete details about your
experience and achievements to make your
resume more compelling instead of saying
worked with stakeholders specify
collaborated with cross-functional teams
and stakeholders to gather requirements
and ensure alignment
so this is how you can structure your
business analyst resume for success
so are you interested to take your
career in business analysis to the next
level introducing the post Gadget
program in business analysis brought to
you by simply learn in collaboration
with Purdue University enrolling in this
program not only equips you with
valuable knowledge but also opens the
doors to endless possibilities
you will get certificate from Simply
learn in collaboration with Purdue
University you will become eligible to
be a part of the Purdue University
Alumni Association and you will master
classes delivered by Purdue faculty and
much more
so what are you waiting for enroll now
and unlock your potential with
industry's leading program in business
analysis
also listen to our Learners what they
has to say about our course
I have many small gaps and short
Employments in my career
I even have a huge two-year career Gap
due to some health issues however I
think the dark times are now behind me
hi I'm Cortana rijik I live in Raleigh
North Carolina and working as a business
analyst at reviture
this is my second job since I completed
the postgraduate program in business
analytics I simply learned with Purge
University my experience with simple
learning was great the live classes were
my favorite because they were very
interactive and I could connect with
instructors it doesn't matter how
challenging the path may be keep
upscaling and one day you will achieve
success in life
now let's understand the common mistakes
to avoid in the resume of business
analyst so here are some mistakes to
widen business analysis you may that is
irrelevant information
avoid including irrelevant details or
experiences that do not pertain to the
business analyst rule
second point is generic language using
vague or generic terms without providing
concrete examples of your skills and
contributions can make your resume less
compelling third is lengthy and
cluttered resume
keep your resuming on size and well
organized focusing on the most relevant
information and using clear headings and
bullet points
then fourth is neglecting keywords
omitting industry specific keywords that
are most important for the role may
result in your resume being overlooked
by both hiring managers and application
tracking systems
so by taking care of these four things
you can avoid common mistakes
now let's understand the importance of
matching your resume to the job
description
so matching your resume to the job
description of a business analyst is
crucial for several reasons firstly it
demonstrates your understanding of the
specific requirements and qualifications
sought by the employer by highlighting
relevant skills that align with the job
description you increase your chances of
getting noticed by the recruiters
secondly it showcases your attention to
detail and professionalism indicating
that you have taken the time to tailor
your application to the position
this effort indicates your genuine
interest in the role and your commitment
to meeting the company needs
ultimately a well-matched resume
increases the likelihood of securing an
interview and positions
I repeat ultimately a well-matched
resume increases the likelihood of
securing an interview and positions you
as a strong candidate for business
analyst position
here's how you can use keywords
effectively and examples of keywords you
can include in your business analysis
resume
so analyze job postings so review
multiple job postings to business
analyst positions to identify common
keywords used by employers pay attention
to technical skills industry specific
terminology and desired qualification
example keywords data analysis
requirement Gathering process
Improvement stakeholder management
business process modeling project
management data visualization
so these were the example keywords now
let's understand the second part which
is Taylor you're assuming customize your
resume by incorporent relevant keywords
from the job description into your
skills
highlight your Proficiency in using
these keywords by providing specific
examples of how you applied them in
previous rules
example conduct in-depth data analysis
using SQL to identify Trends and
patterns
resulting in actionable insights that
drove a 15 increase in sales revenue
third is use variation of keywords use
synonyms and variations of keywords to
demonstrate a broad range of skills and
increase the likelihood of matching the
different job postings
examples are instead of just using
requirement Gathering you can also
include elicitation of business
requirements then capturing user needs
or gathering functional specifications
so this is how you can use the keywords
effectively in your business analyst
resume
so these were some points and things
that you should keep in mind while
making business analyst resume
so if you can take care of these things
you can easily find a job
and become a business analyst
so if you are really interested in
becoming a business analyst you can
check our program postgraduate program
in business analysis
the course link is in the description
box
alright guys with that we have come to
the end of this video If you like this
video please give it a thumbs up I hope
it will help you all thanks for watching
stay safe and keep learning
staying ahead in your career requires
continuous learning and upskilling
whether you're a student aiming to learn
today's top skills or a working
professional looking to advance your
career we've got you covered explore our
impressive catalog of certification
programs in Cutting Edge domains
including data science cloud computing
cyber security AI machine learning or
digital marketing designed in
collaboration with leading universities
and top corporations and delivered by
industry experts choose any of our
programs and set yourself on the path to
Career Success click the link in the
description to know more
foreign
hi there if you like this video
subscribe to the simply learned YouTube
channel and click here to watch similar
videos turn it up and get certified
click here